[Music]
so apparently there was a big explosion
in deep space somewhere that has now
begun hurdling what they call the devil
Comet which is three times the size of
Mount Everest wow wordss our planet
no how how come this isn't bigger news
because technically cuz they're pretty
confident they're not nothing's 100% but
they're pretty confident it's not going
to hit us but is hurling toward us to a
point where it will create enough of a
spectacle that you should be able to see
it with the naked eye oh wow hear
something romantic all right what is you
named this Comet after Gio for like a
million dollars I know I was reading
somewhere what's the big planet closest
to us is it Jupiter the Moon Yeah
Jupiter so though because I thought Mars
was because Jupiter has so much gravity
and as we're going through space the
reason why we don't get hit by asteroids
is because of like the gravitational
pole whatever it creates kind of like
the forest field around Earth
nerd oh man I'll see what
sidee it's it's our hero yeah it's
saving us R's like I wish you didn't say
that man for not again I read it off a
Snapple cap wait what's the RO SLE cap
hey what's the romance part of that I
wasn't sure either it's protecting us
Jupiter takes care of us that's going to
protect us from this big Comet thing
yeah you don't go to you don't go to
Jupiter to be the stupid
wait but what if like the comet's not
going towards us and then Jupiter pulls
it towards us oh that's not how it works
pulls a little
farther it would have never came here
that that was convincing how is it how's
it going to happen it goes just just
check it
out drink a Snapple once in a while yeah
it's not staying still we're moving
that's true so it's moving and it's
going like this yeah and it's like one
in a million anyway could just be one in
10 million chances but people still win
the lottery
though last our last like backup is
[__] shooting some sort of laser at
before it get D we just nuke it bro same
laser that burned Maui yeah yeah May
I'll take dude yeah I'll take people
were not talking about the spakes laser
yo yeah so with an estimated diameter of
18.6 Miles which is huge as [__] it's
like [__] the length of La it is
three times the size of Mount Everest
like I said earlier which is almost the
same as La we're using Everest thanks
yeah well I never seen Mount Everest so
I don't know how to Rose Meat I
think yeah can you change it can you put
that I think they need to make it la
like oh yeah so in 45 minutes of traffic
driving yeah in Los Angeles which is
only like from monre Park to San Gabriel
that's like that's like 12 miles fast
pass but this up you guys remember
watching the era of [__] both
Armageddon and Deep Impact yeah dude all
right obviously AR Independence Day did
you do you saying Aragon's better as a
movie as a movie yeah it is I AG better
soundtrack too oh you sounded like you I
was waiting for attack him be
like it's the music video that got me
she's
like see that's romantic that's way more
romantic that's your Jupiter thing stop
trying to get us to like Jupiter we're
not going to like Jupiter this guy
always brings it up Jupiter's got a cool
dud we're like no Jupiter's late stop
campaigning for other planets
Saturn he's got get to know Jupiter you
know
Saturn hey Saturn was also the cooler
looking Planet it didn't have a pimp
sell me on Saturn right now sell us on
Saturn the infinite rings of awesome oh
that's cool but that's just space dust a
giant red pimple well okay with a lot of
love but Neptune always gets slept on
yeah people forget about Neptune they
don't really tell them about tell them
they don't know let us know tell tell
them about Neptune bro Neptune it's
gassy dude oh it's gassy that's better
line for Uranus that's true damn that's
a good one yeah but didn't they just
find out that [__] ain't need even a
planet they keep flip flopping Pluto
Pluto's
out technically out but then it's like
back in but then it's out man my
friend's [__] 3-year-old son knows
all the plan
cuz it's the smallest one isn't it isn't
Pluto a small small guy pick on the
dwarf you know it was a it was a moon
does Pluto have
as maybe maybe it has asthma like you
can't hang with us dude you know the
last time a com hit us the dinosaurs
died yeah had him had it coming honestly
you better do it job God struck him down
dude not romantic it was a breakup it
was a break God didn't like how the
dinosaurs were living so he [__]
struck them down we're probably going to
die by the same thing yeah dude that's
what do you think we have to do to get
struck down by God with a comet by
actual God by an Ice Age actual God we I
don't know we've been doing some horny
[__] these days I don't know if got be
cool with that like what kind of horny
[__] he's over it right he goes man you
guys [__] doing that horny [__] again
[__] fu just do what you want cuz that
the last time he he struck down was when
the Romans were getting too horny like
man you guys [__] [__] other D I
got to [__] do this and
then and then you reset that [__] and
then people are like oh you know what
like you guys got to be a church now we
got to be married we got to have kids we
can't be [__] around we got to all
right let's be boring let's grow some
beats and then [__] live life like
that yeah yep and I think he does that
every couple when we get too horny he
almost had a time interval that he when
we get too
hard
so if we if we knew if you guys knew
that we were literally facing extinction
like this PL come in that you know they
put the giant clock on [__] TV for no
reason for anxiety it's like T minus
like 12 days and 38 whatever what would
you guys be doing [__] and suck it
dude we're going to [__] a sucking
You' be sucking why you point at me not
[__] a sucking I'm not [__] a
sucking you I'm just saying like like
what Joe was saying pointing in your
direction like what Joe was saying like
referring to his last name that just
goes to his point going get more horny
yeah people already do it they're going
to purge I feel like most people
wouldn't believe it even if it was like
oh it's real this time guys and they did
all too many things had not happened
even with a DJ clock I mean if you live
through Y2K this would probably be like
Y2K was it yeah but Y2K was like
conceptual with digital software seem
like peanuts compared to this we're
talking like seeing a physical anomaly
that's heading towards us it's growing
day byday visually like coming in and
probably people are hella scared now
because of we you know we just had the
pandemic right so now anything can
happen yeah that's true true so like you
you're saying asteroid's coming and
fizer comes out with a vaccine for it no
no I'm just people would like will
believe that things are it's going to
happen in the world [__] 12 days yeah
sure 12 days that's a lot of days if
it's coming towards America cuz now you
get to do a lot I feel like Americans
would actually just pull their guns out
of stuff I got this
[__] could you imagine us just shooting
in the sky that would be so crazy that's
the American way damn that would be a
sick ass La last tactic though for like
just the world to just put their G up
what if it does it's going toward Texas
and everyone's
just and it actually breaks it up into
small pieces and being like the rich
people in the space station watching
like with your coffee and you just see
the Earth just like that's an AR-15
going
on brings the world together that's
probably why Elon and those guys are
making those space
shuttles on dudey as
[__] damn all of that Mr
Branson is wait does bessos have a space
thing yeah he has a space program
they're all doing it man Mr
bessos they're all building it up
because they knew this [__] was coming
way before they're playing the long game
so it's like all right what is my
[__] Escape Plan cuz then they have
to launch comic comes down and as
private contractors they're probably
privy to like confidential information
they let know because of yeah but they
know and all the rich people have like
tickets already to the space station I'm
sure oh yeah they're chilling well it's
got to be like Noah Arc right they're
probably choosing at least one person of
every category so you might be like the
one fight coordinator that they're bring
up you need one of everything we need a
b coordinator on here yeah that's true
how are we going to get our Chinese
Theater up
here I'm like pick
me like the masks yeah Chinese
Opera have you ever seen on Simpsons
when that happened and then um like they
the whole world thought they were going
to be extinct so everyone from the
church ran to the bar and everyone from
the bar ran to the
church sick that's the best explanation
so fun that's the best explanation right
there what would
happened I wonder what would people do
lard
Jiu-Jitsu well I think first people
would stop going to work yeah so then
all the stuff like from
just end H yeah like you need things to
run no more no plumbers bro everything
you think you guys think people get more
violent or more I think there'll be Mass
suicides yeah like like people just
start purging yeah but I also think that
themselves Dam if governments don't
announce it I think there'll be a lot of
Skeptics I think they'll still be
Skeptics even if Government anybody who
needed to exact Vengeance for any reason
would just [__] go dude that's crazy
they did confirm that it was real do you
think they would even announce it I
don't don't think so that's why but if
they did announce it then it's going to
be in all the movies they always don't
for as long as possible and then at the
very last moment when there's no other
chice protagonist leaks it they do in
order to just make sure people are just
like spend time with your loved ones
it's the end guys and remember the
person who still always goes to work is
the last news reporter who's always on
the air to the last moment to be with
everybody yeah they're the people people
at the hurricanes in Florida that's
still reporting well there's all this
wind and then the palm trees are going
like this yeah no but there's always
some white lady that's like I like
jogging in hurricanes it's the best
condition that's like the black ice
girl she eats [__] bro it was so bad
that was a concussion for sure that's my
favorite running [__] whenever I'm sad I
just watched dude it's just so great out
here asid's coming he's watching that
video and then if you see them uh
recording the waves and a hurricane
there's always some crazy Surfer that's
like
and he's just like yeah dud my friends
were all surfing that last this last one
they were just like
[Music]
yeah